mais on va poursuivre quand même cette
découverte de ce lieu absolument magique
avec arnaud qui est membre de la troupe
dès minuit ici c'est le grand jardin du
théâtre dès minuit oui c'est un jardin
mais c'est aussi un lieu de création un
lieu de représentation un lieu vingt
mètres qui a plein d'une plainte
d'utilité différentes et qui dans tous
les cas est un lieu fort agréable dans
lequel on peut venir se perdre un petit
peu a lancé perdu un petit peu dans la
forêt interdite nous ça va encore le
chemin il est bien tracée et on à faire
du coup vous aperçu c'est vrai mais vous
à récupérer et on vous récupère un très
très beau moment puisque là on s'apprête
à rentrer dans la roseraie mais tout à
l'heure quand on a justement perdu tout
le monde
on était en train de vous faire
découvrir ça et ouais ça c'est quoi ça
c'est votre coup de coeur ça c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous avez décidé
d'installer la troupe ici finalement
ah oui alors vous parlez de vous parler
du château d'accord d'accord
oui oui c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles on s'est installé là nous ont
cherché comme je vous ai dit une plutôt
une ferme des bâtiments pour installer
des ateliers de décors des ateliers de
costumes des salles de répétition
et puis on est tombé sur ce bâtiment qui
était installée dans les ruines de ce
château qui date d environ 2500
et effectivement qui constitue un décor
là encore très beau très beau pour pour
unis c'est un décor je sais plus ce
qu'on a ce que j'ai dit avant qu'on soit
cool ce château à dieppe en religion
démonter quelques très beaux restes
trois murs d'enceinte de tours une
grande tour escaliers puis les restes
d'un logis donc il ne reste pas grand
chose mais ce pas grand-chose constitue
un très beau décor
voilà victor hugo aurait adoré et puis
moi j'adore donc ça me convient
parfaitement
du coup depuis cet endroit là on vient
un très beau moment de la balade puisque
ça y est c'est fleuri ça y est c'est
coloré
ça y est c'est de la rose et c'est pas
n'importe quel rose parce que là aussi
le personnage qu'il ya derrière cette
roseraie il est très très important pour
vous on voulait on voulait donc que ce
jardin soit connecté aux territoires
alentours et aussi aux gens qui
travaillaient et on voulait que ce
jardin parle de création et donc on a
rencontré andré eve qui vivait habiter
travailler à pithiviers donc pas très
loin d'ici et au départ on voulait on
lui a proposé de collectionner toutes
les nouvelles variétés de roses qu'il a
créés au cours de sa carrière
je précise si jamais quelqu'un n'a
jamais entendu parler d'être d'andré eve
on ne vous jugera pas c'est un très
grand rosiéristes qui étaient ici à
pithiviers qui vivait ici et qui a des
vins dévolu sa vie aux roses qui en a
créé de nouvelles trouver des anciennes
qui la fait revivre et les collections
enfin les collections de rose de manière
générale
il va en profiter de sa vision de 12 ans
travaillent finalement il nous a quittés
il ya quelques années mais lui en tout
cas il a pris le temps de vous aider à
construire ce lieu est ce lieu c'est lui
en fait oui oui c'est plus que de la dit
il a vraiment dessiner la roseraie et
nous ici avec julien qui a qui a créé ce
jardin avec moi on était vraiment on
s'est mis totalement au service de son
projet paysager c'est à dire que dans
cette partie du jardin dans le jardin de
roses c'est vraiment andré eve qui a
choisi toutes les plantes les
emplacements jusqu'à la plus petite
vivaces vraiment ici chaque fois ont
planté avec son avis conforme donc nous
on a vraiment c'est vraiment on a été
les petites mains de ce jardin mais
c'est bien lui le concepteur d'un bout à
l'autre de ce jardin de roses alors et
donc on a collectionné ici toutes les
huiles huit arrivées avec deux idées un
rassembler toutes ces variétés toutes
les variétés encore une fois qu'il a
créée de sa main au cours de sa vie
nouvelles variétés de roses et présenter
ses nouvelles variétés en compagnie des
rosiers père et mère qui l'a utilisé
pour ces hybridations on en a un bon
exemple ici en ce moment
on est accueilli par un parent massif où
il y as au centre est
la mère de tous les rosiers au tour donc
centenaire de lourdes c'est un rosier
créé par chabbert dans les années 50
pour delbarre le rose clair là bas sont
au centre voilà qui est unique en dre
avait choisi comme maire parce que c'est
un rosier qui fructifie bien et qui a eu
des cas de la santé oms on le voit il ya
de l'opulence et il la croisait avec un
petit rosiers ici qui s'appelle heydrich
munch
il est en fleurs voilà c'est ce rose
nacré
voilà et on a le résultat de
l'hybridation ici un rosier donc une
variété créé par andré eve qui
s'appellent sandrine on a donc le la
variété d'andré en compagnie des rosiers
père et mère qui l'a utilisé encore une
fois pour pour faire cette hybridation
en fait on a rassemblé les familles tout
en somme c'est ça c'est ça et est de ce
point de vue cette roseraie c'est ce que
lui disait en tout cas est unique au
monde c'est la seule à être consacré un
seul obtenteurs à et à collectionner les
variétés d'un obtenteurs et c'est la
seule aussi être présentées sur ce
principe de mise en avant du travail de
création de l'obtenteur on va avancer
par là bas parce que là aussi alors
quand on n'est pas un connaisseur de
rose on peut pas forcément le deviner
mais là il ya eu une main l'idée a été
de respecter et de décrypter un petit
peu l'histoire de la rose en tout cas
comment elle a fait son chemin pour
devenir l'une des fleurs préférées
aujourd'hui finalement des gens c'est ça
hein
ici c'est l'histoire de la rose sous nos
yeux oui c'est quelque chose qui vous
l'avez dit andré a été un des grands
rénovateurs de la rose ancien en france
et il a tout au long de sa vie
collectionner des variétés de roses
anciennes et notamment ce qu'il
considérait comme les grands rosiers
étapes de l'histoire de la rose est ici
il en a présenté une courte une courte à
un cours un court résumé vous avez ici
voilà à l'ailé les grands ancêtres
européens de nos rosiers horticole
actuelle c'est à dire tout simplement
l'églantier et rosa gallica je suis pas
sûr qu'on la voit à l'image mais mais
après on va découvrir une rose qui était
déjà présente au moyen âge dans les
jardins c'est rosa gallica versicolor
c'est celle qui est à l'image je pense
en ce moment on aura ensuite une rose
ici ma qui est très connu aussi du grand
public à la fuchsia framboise derrière
derrière la rose et voilà c'est rosa
gallica officialise donc c'est la
célèbre rose de provins après on avance
encore dans le temps on arrive à la
renaissance avec cuisse de nymphe qui a
la particularité de sentir très fort
elles sont très très très bon et
puis à la ce coloris rose et
ces puits puis ce nom qui est
extraordinaire - fils de 9
voilà ça fait tout de suite son petit
effet voilà on avance encore dans le
temps on arrive au xviiie siècle et les
premières rencontres entre les rosiers
européen on est on est on est dans les
rosiers européens et vous aurez remarqué
que tous ces rosiers pour l'instant sont
neuf le risque une fois dans l'année
pour pour que les rosiers se met à
remonter il va falloir que les rosiers
européens rencontrent les rosiers
asiatiques
et voilà on en a un petit exemplaire ici
qui s'appelle old blush c'est c'est une
variété qu'andré andré quand il disait
que c'était la variété obtenu est
cultivée par l'homme la plus ancienne
connue parce qu on a des soie chinoise
du 11e siècle qui représente déjà cette
fleur donc on sait qui est que cette
variété à au moins 1000 en quoi est elle
remonte et en croisant des rosiers
européens avec notamment paul bloch et
ben les rosiers vont récupérer cette
qualité de remonter ça c'est essayer un
truc vous m'apprenez vraiment parce que
je sais pas moi j'ai pensé que ça existe
depuis toujours les rosiers remontants
que ça faisait partie du bas de
certaines variétés et pas d'autres je ne
savais pas que c'était un croisement
avec eux avec lorient qui leur avait
permis de devenir comme ça alors tout à
l'heure vous nous parliez donc du papa
de la maman du petit toujours on a
toujours centenaire de lourdes
ici donc qui a été une très très bonne
mère c'est andré qu'il disait
puisqu'elle a été la mère du de la
première variété mise au commerce y'a
pas de fleurs là aujourd'hui donc bon
mais mise premières variétés mises au
commerce par andré qui a été un de ses
grands succès c'est sylvie vartan donc
le rosier sylvie vartan qui est là bas
mais qui n'a pas de fleurs aujourd'hui
je suis désolé et en inami si vous avez
quand même fait un effort mais je leur
ai demandé pourtant j'étais là tous les
matins à dire allez vas-y
france 3 arrive mais non c'est raté
c'est raté et donc et donc andré mais
bien raconter cette histoire il a croisé
donc voici voici centenaire de lourdes
là-bas sylvie vartan il a croisé sylvie
vartan avec un petit rozier qui lui est
en fleurs merci à lui il s'appelle lili
marlène et ça a donné un rosier qui a
failli s'appeler johnny hallyday mais
entre temps sylvie et johnny se sont
séparés donc le rosier qui aurait pu
s'appeler johnny s'est appelée prestige
de bellegarde et ses seins magnifiques
rosiers rose d'or 1976 il porte très
bien son nom mais quand même on peut
regretter parce que johnny hallyday a
failli être le fils de sylvie vartan et
là franchement on était bien perturbé
quoi mais c'est très drôle à roubaix pas
ma question va être terrible après tout
cette gelée vous dis alors quand il
faisait justement ces croisements quand
il faisait ses associations d'un rosier
mal d'un rosier femelle d'un papa et
d'une maman on va dire ça comme ça ou de
papa et de maman peu importe dans les
plantes c'était possible mais quand il
faisait ça est ce que le résultat était
toujours enfin est ce que chacun des
résultats a donné lieu à chaque fois une
belle rose qui a intégré la collection
qui a été commercialisé
j'imagine que ça marchait peut-être pas
toujours tout ça
donc il disait que globalement le rosier
dit pais rapporte la fleur les qualités
esthétiques parfum et voilà et que le
rosier mer on recherchait plus tôt le
port et la vigueur la résidence ou
maladie etc donc donc il ya quand même
une volonté quand encore l'obtenteur
croiser derosier il a une idée il a une
idée de ce qu'ils cherchent mais il va
pas forcément trouvé
parce que parce que voilà c'est les
mystères de la génétique aussi il ya le
hasard et et ça fait partie du processus
de création c'est ça qui nous plaît bien
aussi parce que nous on connaît bien ça
aussi chercher chercher parfois c'est le
hasard qui va nous amener à trouver
quelque chose d'intéressant ce n'était
pas forcément ce qu'on cherchait et puis
parfois aussi il ya des ya des étapes
il ya des échecs il ya des impasses et
c'est une des choses intéressantes dans
cette roseraie c'est qu'on a rassemblé
quand je vous ai dit qu'on avait
rassemblé toutes les variétés créé par
andré encore disponibles on a rassemblé
aussi des variétés qui n'a pas misé au
commerce
c'était à ça que je voulais vous faire
arriver en fait c'est ça que je vais
vous faire dire mais c'est un petit peu
plus loin donc on va continuer à se
balader je voulais tout à l'heure je les
j'ai commencé à l'annoncé en fait cette
roseraie on peut aussi s'y balader avec
la voix d'andré f dans nos oreilles mais
comme d'autres lieux de ce jardin qu'on
peut venir explorer et on peut se faire
accompagner justement par différentes
personnes via un casque un lecteur mp3
on dit comme ça on se dit ah bah non
c'est mieux d'entendre le vent dans les
branchages mais ça peut être pas mal
aussi
oui on propose des visites des visites
des balades sonores on appelle ça les
balades sonores mans ce sont différentes
personnalités qui sont interviewés on
associe toujours quelqu'un avec un
créateur sonore
la première de ces balades sonores c'est
avec andré f sur la base d'une interview
réalisée par boris billets et
effectivement on peut se promener dans
cette roseraie en écoutant cette pièce
sonore et et en étant guidé par andré
lui-même qui raconte à peu près les
anecdotes que je raconte aussi parce que
voilà elle me viennent de lui
et
et voilà et donc on a eu une balade
sonore avec andrev la seconde a été fait
avec une autre iskareen serre qui a
imaginé un récit imaginaire sur ce sur
ce jardin une visite totalement
fantasmagorique sur ce jardin
la troisième a été fait avec le
sculpteur le grand sculpteur jean guerra
qui est un habitué aussi de ce lieu et
n'habite pas très loin d'ici et nous
sommes des grands admirateurs de son
oeuvre donc on lui a demandé de nous
proposer une balade
c'est la plus longue des trois n'a pas
combien de temps elle fait mais elle est
longue mais elle vous permet de vraiment
bien profiter des lieux bien ça aussi
justement voilà il ya différents temps
il ya différents selon selon le temps
qu'on a envie de consacrer à ce lieu
qu'on a envie d'y passer on peut choisir
différentes balades
la quatrième a été fait avec la voix des
enfants de l'école maternelle dont deux
villes sur essonne est donc là c'est une
visite du jardin avec les remarques les
les
les voix des enfants qui se promène dans
ce jardin et qui proposent leurs regards
sur sur le jardin et puis la dernière en
date c'est avec bernadette després et là
aussi c'est une très très belle balade
sonore parce qu'on se promène dans ce
jardin en compagnie de bernadette qui
est en train de dessiner
ll est en train de dessiner dans ce
jardin des histoires de tom tom et nana
dans le dans dans la roseraie tom tom et
nana dans le château tom tom et nana
dans la prairie etc alors est-ce qu'on
n'est pas arrivé
c'est extrêmement intéressant parce que
ça c'est vraiment un document sur la
aussi le processus créatif comment
comment comment elle aborde un dessin
comment elle ne crée vraiment très très
intéressant et dans toutes ses balles je
crois qu'ils les différents artistes que
vous avez sollicité parlent de leur
rapport aux jardins parlent de leur
rapport à la création enfin toutes ces
choses là
toutes ces thématiques qui font
finalement l'essence même de ce jardin
juste une petite chose
ben oui quand même on parlait de papa
maman et d'enfants et de rosiers étape
donc qui n'ont pas tous été
commercialisé en l'occurrence celui ci
ne l'a pas été andré pardon c'est un
rosier andré appelé julie qui
effectivement n'a pas été mise au
commerce parce que comme vous le voyez à
l'image lafleur ne s'ouvre pas ce qui
est un gros défaut quand même pour une
rose mais mais mais elle a une qualité
somptueuse elle a un parfum absolument
extraordinaire et donc andré qui avait
créé ce rosier l'a utilisé pour essayer
de transmettre à d'autres variétés ce
caractère de parfums exceptionnel donc
donc c'est bien c'est bien le travail de
la création de l'obtenteur avec ses
étapes avec encore une fois à ses
réussites éclatantes et puis ces semi
échec ou où ces étapes de travail qui
vont permettre d'aller vers autre chose
quoi tellement du qu'on arrive au bout
de cette roseraie
vous avez dû le remarquer tout au long
de notre balade ya cette immense étendue
à côté de nous qui
et qui est en mouvement tout le temps
parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya pas mal de
vent et du coup ça ça fait un très très
beau paysage moi j'adore ça
on va s'engouffrer dans ce lieu comment
vous l'avez appelé arnaud
c'est ce lieu là il a une importance
pour vous en plus il a une très grande
importance on l'a mis au centre du
jardin et ses bas hasard c'est une
prairie et on avait vraiment envie que
cette prairie c'est à dire encore une
fois un espace naturel soit au centre du
jardin c'est lui qui presque les autres
jardins sont presque prélevés sur la
prairie cesser la prairie qui
scénographie l'ensemble du jardin
et oui c'est un endroit extrêmement
important parce qu on propose aux gens
de voir aussi les plantes qui composent
cette prairie et est considérée s'est
planté cet endroit oui je ne cède pas
été visée parce que pour les fans de
jardin quand vous leur imposez sur un
hectare on va dire allez ça doit bien
faire
soixante pour cent de la superficie
comme vous l'a proposé de ça il doit
venir un peu ou taper sur les doigts
il ya un petit côté provoc
voilà c'est vrai dans ce jardin on est
accueilli par lortie il ya de la prairie
il y a
oui oui il ya un petit côté provoc mais
mais mais c'est aussi le jardin d'un
théâtre est donc ce qu'on essaye de
provoquer c'est la réflexion aussi c'est
de provoquer la réflexion
il ya plein de gens effectivement qui
arrivent ici en étant assez surpris et
qui repartent en disant ah mais je vais
repenser la façon dont j'entretiens mon
verger à ça m'a donné envie de voilà ou
même parfois des gens qui disent et ça
c'est extraordinaire qui disent je
n'avais jamais osé
j'avais jamais osé laisser pousser
l'herbe c'est quand même fou quoi de se
dire que c'est à ce point presque ouais
ouais c'est pas tabou mais mais mais
ouais il ya quelque chose
il ya d'abord une notion de propreté au
jardin et la propreté c'est d'abord
l'herbe tondue nickel pas loin du désert
quand même
et
effectivement la halle à cet endroit
il accueille les animaux il a il ya bien
sûr un aspect esthétique un vous l'avez
dit moi j'adore comme vous le mouvement
du vent dans dans l'herbe sa sollicite
le regard ça sollicite l'imaginaire les
enfants adorent cette zone parce qu'on
le voit peut-être pas encore mais il ya
des allées qui sont tendues dans cet
endroit est là c'est un nom qui est
investi très très souvent par par les
enfants qui courent qui se cache alors
ce que je veux et puis pardon mais mais
qu'est-ce que j'utilisais un endroit
vous disais que c'était un endroit qui
était très investi par les enfants mais
je sais pas si ça vous aide à vous mais
bon bah tant pis alors moi je vais
continuer sur ce que je voulais vous
dire parce que je vous sais qu'on compte
tourner cette pré j'aimerais j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'on s'engouffre dedans mais
on va perdre notre amie cécile au
passage et est du coup du coup je
voudrais qu'on continue on va reprend là
les centrales pour aller vers le baisser
de rideau final
ok entre temps j'aimerais quand même
qu'on parle de ce qui va se passer dans
ce lieu là déjà vous l'avez dit c'est un
lieu que vous avez ouvert à la visite le
grand jardin un lieu dans lequel on peut
être à distance les uns des autres dans
lequel on peut se faire plaisir dans
lequel on peut se ressourcer et
d'ailleurs je crois que les premiers
week-ends où vous avez ouvert ça
cartonnait on a on a été très surpris
dès qu'on a rouvert on a pu rouvrir le
jardin avant de rouvrir le théâtre 1
et dès le premier dimanche d'ouverture
il ya eu énormément de monde ici parce
qu'effectivement on l'a dit un jardin
c'est aussi un endroit rassurant où il
ya de la place on peut être à distance
effectivement comme vous l'avait dit et
puis on est dehors on est à l'air libre
il ya du vent
oui c'est un endroit de ce oui oui il ya
une certaine tranquillité quoi eh oui
donc le grand jardin on peut venir quand
alors on peut y venir tous les dimanches
de 17h à 20h on a choisi cette web c'est
la première année qu'on ouvre sur ce
créneau horaire
parce qu'en fait
le jardin est très beau à la lumière
descendant tout à la lumière montante
ça met en valeur les reliefs et donc on
avait envie de proposer ça aux gens de
découvrir le jardin à la meilleure en
fait et la meilleure c'est vraiment
entre 17h et 20h
donc ça c'est tous les dimanches avec on
propose des visites guidées 17h30 et
18h30
il ya un food truck le temps d'une
promenade qui est installée derrière
nous et qui propose chocolat et amar est
fait à la demande c'est pas pour l'heure
de goûter c'est pas mal et est donc on
peut aussi profiter des balades sonores
à ce moment là et puis très
prochainement
reprise de la programmation artistique
dans le jardin le 14
juin prochain sellem belloc une
chanteuse estonienne autrice
compositrice interprète extraordinaire
qui sera en concert ici donc ça c'est le
14 juin à 16h
ensuite elle reviendra la semaine
suivante le 21 avec une chorale éphémère
en fait c'est un projet qui devait se
tenir pendant le confinement en réel en
présentiel comme on dit maintenant et et
qui n'a pas pu se tenir donc à la elle a
quand même fait assurer les répétitions
par internet
donc il ya des gens qui ont appris les
chansons etc et ils vont se retrouver
ici le 21 pour un concert chorale
éphémère
les vidéos sont encore disponibles
d'ailleurs en ligne donc on peut encore
travailler les chances cirque comme moi
je peux rentrer dans cette chorale même
même vous dites donc c'est pas beau ça
je pense qu'apple va m'entendre chanter
ma petite tête et annulé le projet donc
vingt toiles a en tout cas tout le monde
peut encore
d'ici au 21 travail et les chansons et
nous retrouver ici pour le concert de la
chorale éphémère de leyme belloc le 20
heures
on en est et où on en était au 21 juin
je vois tellement fait de la musique
donc ce sera un très joli projet pour
cette date la suite ce sera
clémentine de couture avec la compagnie
divague une chanteuse lyrique de grand
talent qui sera aussi dans le jardin en
concert donc ça c'est le 28 juin à 16h
les prochains événements bas 5 juillet
début du chantier de bénévoles
internationaux auxquels tout le monde là
aussi le droit de s'inscrire à partir de
17 ans donc c'est à partir du 5 juillet
des gens qui viennent du monde entier et
aussi de régions centre et de pas loin
et du pithiverais l'idc les vignes à
vous aider à remettre en état autant que
possible ce château c'est ça on
stabilise en stabilise progressivement
la ruine
on rénove progressivement la ruine pour
à terme l'ouvrir aussi à la visite et au
spectacle donc ça c'est à partir du 5
juillet il ya deux sessions de 15 jours
donc une session qui commence le 5 et
une session qui commence deux semaines
après et puis le 13 juillet et le 14
août
on accueillera là aussi dans le jardin
le spectacle de jérôme marin le secret
voilà qui sera installée dans le jardin
vous allez lui faire une petite place à
quel endroit
ah bin là où il voudra là où il voudra
pas ce que je voulais pas encore
raconter mais la prairie c'est aussi une
scène c'est aussi une page blanche qui
attend et donc quand arrive un spectacle
ici on tond fauche une scénographie
d'herbe pour accueillir le spectacle
donc donc bien là aussi on se mettra à
sa disposition pour est à la disposition
du spectacle pur pour l'installer aussi
convenablement que possible dans ce
grand jardin
alors on est arrivé pas du tout au goût
de notre vite mais peut-être au bout de
ce qu'on va vous proposer comme balade
aujourd'hui et on s'arrête quand même un
endroit bon parce que c'est un lieu
symbolique là aussi qu'est ce que vous
avez mis dans ces grands carrés là en
fait ici ses bas c'est la classe n
comment dire c'est là que le rideau se
referme et glace elle s'arrête où
s'ouvre en fait là on est dans l'allée
centrale qui mène les spectateurs quand
les spectateurs viennent pour un
spectacle voilà il empruntait l'allée
centrale et donc ils vont traverser le
rideau rouge le rideau rouge le red dot
fruits rouges en aidant on est dans le
jardin d'un théâtre et donc on a planté
dernière un rideau de fruits rouges donc
cdc des plans de tout à fait classique
un groseilliers kck zeiller cassissiers
fraisiers et puis qu'est-ce que puis
groseilliers
voilà donc des fruits rouges et pour
pour aller au théâtre il faut traverser
ce rideau de fruits rouges ça nous amuse
et bien bien sûr c'est une blague mais
mais ça nous amusait bien d'avoir ce
rideau rouge dans notre jardin oui à
quelques ya peut-être qu'il ya quelques
petites fraises et quelques framboises
qui nous font de l'oeil je pense qu'on
va comme ça il ya d'autres espaces qu'on
n'a pas découvert
on ne va pas vous en parler parce que le
but c'est que vous veniez jusqu'ici que
vous veniez assister à un concert que
vous veniez simplement vous balader
quand le soleil décline le dimanche soir
en juin et l'idée c'est que vous ayez la
chance vous aussi de faire cette balade
pourquoi pas avec un mot pourquoi pas
avec jérôme c'est ça qui est julien
baron qui a créé ce jardin avec vous qui
continuent de l'entretenir avec vous il
ya vraiment d'autres espaces à découvrir
donc ce que je vous encourage à faire
vous tapez théâtre dès minuit il ya un
très beau site internet
il y a une page facebook qui a tout sur
les réseaux sociaux donc vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les infos pour venir
jusqu'ici il ya une programmation qui
j'imagine vous est certainement en train
de réfléchir à la suite aussi oui elle a
été
elle a été perturbée par par la crise du
coc vide évidemment mais mais il ya
aussi des choses qui s'improvisent c'est
une des choses qui a été intéressante
ce jardin a aussi été un refuge un
jardin c'est aussi un refuge c'est aussi
un abri pour l'humain et pour ce qui est
pour son travail il ya beaucoup
d'artistes binger qui se sont tournés
vers le théâtre et son jardin pendant
pendant la crise parce que parce que
encore une fois dans un jardin c'est
plus facile d'accueillir le spectacle
vivant et donc il ya une programmation
aussi qui est en train de se monter qui
était pas prévu mais mais voilà qui
s'improvisent avec cette sortie de
confinement et c'est plutôt pas mal
aussi de se dire que qu'un jardin
décidément c'est aussi une certaine
résilience c'est un mois à la mode mais
mais c'est une capacité à protéger à
absorber les crises et
et encore une fois c'est un endroit où
on est bien on est bien pour travailler
aussi travailler exactement ce qu'on a
fait cet après midi mais ça m'a pas du
tout donner l'impression qu'on était en
train de travailler donc merci beaucoup
beaucoup théâtre dès minuit le grand
jardin du théâtre dès minuit c'était la
balade qu'on vous a proposé aujourd'hui
on vous en proposera peut-être d'autres
et sinon ce que je vous encourage aussi
à faire c'est à regarder tous les autres
jardins qui peut y avoir déjà rien que
dans les alentours ya plein de choses à
voir et à la roseraie de morale du côté
de pithiviers le vieil a le jardin
personnel dans le rêve du côté de
pithiviers aussi bref y'a des lieux
somptueux partout donc renseignez vous
tous les sites de la route de la rose
jardin de la l'aja vallières aussi pas
très loin d'ici
tous les sites de la route de larosière
le châtel jardin d'ordre est
effectivement la eddie morra y est son
jardin personnel dans le sang il ya
plein de choses vous n'avez pas besoin
de partir en vacances il ya tout ce
qu'il faut à proximité de chez vous ou
en tout cas j'espère que la balade vous
a plu malgré tout les petits soucis
techniques on a pu avoir malgré la
distanciation social connaît avec arnaud
avec un seul micro
donc j'espère que ça vous a plu non à
passer un délicieux moment très bon week
end à vous et à très bientôt sur notre
page facebook